I'm pretty cynical by nature but the
last two months of seeing how I don't
know if it's 30 percent or 40 percent of
the country has been dealing with
coronavirus it's really made me lose
like even more faith in humanity than I
had already lost at least American
humanity we already did a story on the
bonus show about how one-third of the
country believes coronavirus was created
deliberately rather than evolving as
viruses do and this is already very very
bad and we increasingly now have the
sort of Liberty crowd the people that
fetishize a myopic version of what
freedom is starting to protests that we
must open the country many of them have
even been gathering in large groups in
order to demand that the country be
opened and one such rally happened in
Michigan yesterday another one happening
I believe today in Kentucky possibly but
all of today's videos are from yesterday
in Michigan and Michigan's having a real
problem with coronavirus Michigan is in
the top eight states in cases per capita
a Michigan is in the top four states in
deaths per capita and they're not doing
that much testing they're only testing a
30 second per capita in the United
States and of course many states simply
do not have tests it's beyond many
states to be able to do more testing the
point is high death per capita low
testing per capita in Michigan people
have to stay the hell home so here are
protesters gathering in huge groups now
you're going to hear if you're not
watching I'll tell you some of what
you're going to hear you're going to
hear screams of lock her up referring to
Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer
you're going to hear screams of recall
Whitmer you'll hear USA USA chants and
of course what you will see if you're
watching is a huge crowd of people when
we're trying to fight a virus that
spreads through droplet contagion take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here are interviews with two people one
guy crying about being unable to get
lawn fertilizer and a woman complaining
about not being able to dye her gray
roots bending down to show how the roots
are tragically coming in I can't go
between those houses you can't buy paint
you can't fight a law you can't pay lawn
fertilizer or grass seed or whatever
come on all statewide really you know
it's time for our seat to be opened up
we're tired of not being able to buy the
things that we need go to the
hairdresser's get our hair done so I
mean listen the guy who's crying about
fertilizer if you're that desperate for
some manure just watch Trump's daily
press briefings and you'll get more more
than your daily allotment but this is
really really crazy first of all you
know the woman with the hair died 2,500
people died in the United States on on
Wednesday this week from coronavirus
this is the most in one day in any
country since the start of the pandemic
she's complaining about dyeing her hair
is the reason that the state needs to
reopen it also seems like these people
aren't just Oh
either aware or telling the truth about
what's going on in their states because
the guy law you know crying about manure
I looked into it hardware stores are
open in Michigan they will give you
fertilizer they'll even bring you have
to call ahead and give your credit cards
they'll bring it out to your car you can
order it from Amazon Amazon shipments
are taking quite a while right now but
it'll get to you the idea that you know
he's crying because he can't get
fertilizer you can get fertilizer I
don't know if he has access to the
Internet so this is the epitome of the
ugly side of America and it is not lost
on me that both of these individuals
appear to be in high-risk groups based
on their age groups that should really
be staying home right now completely
entitled completely lacking an
understanding of basic science and they
are indignant at others looking to help
people and stay home they're also wrong
on the facts and confused about the
world around them so it's sort of like a
perfect rumpus and I've said it before I
don't want anyone to die from the
but if they were only putting themselves
at risk I would say okay you know what
if people want to risk death and they're
not endangering anyone else let them do
it like how much are we going to fight
them if they're only putting themselves
at risk let it rip so to speak but they
do put others at risk people who do
understand what's going on
recognize that those people are putting
at risk people in a position where they
may get the virus and die their actions
don't only affect themselves they affect
everybody around them so we have to act
collectively here to keep people safe
they will never change their minds until
they and their loved ones get sick and
by then it's going to be told too late
they'll have spread it already
most will still vote for Trump in
November regardless remember when Trump
said his Vietnam was avoiding STDs
during like the 1980s or something like
that for these people not dyeing their
hair as a sacrifice as tens of thousands
of people are dying in health care
workers are in warlike conditions every
day they are considering this a big
battle for them and I get it you know I
I'm sick of being home I want to see
people I want to go out I just want to
sit in a restaurant for a couple of
hours I totally understand it but this
is bigger than any one of us and
particularly for a lot of these folks
who are religious and tend to subscribe
to the idea that there's something
bigger than them that connects to their
actions every single day how is it that
they don't get that same idea applies in
a real way to what we're doing here in
trying to stop the spread it's
disheartening it's concerning it's
disappointing and unfortunately they're
not only putting themselves at risk if
it were only risking their own lives at
certain point I would say go ahead and
do it but that's not the situation let
me tell you real quick about one of our
sponsors cuts clothing they offer super
quality men's t-shirts and they're
giving you 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash cuts that see UTS
because solid color t-shirts are a
really important staple in pretty much
every guy's wardrobe
I think it's really important not to
overlook the value of having t-shirts
you love wearing t-shirts from cuts
clothing have been a game-changer for me
and as a company all they deal with are
men's
solid color t-shirts so they actually
put a ton of thought into the comfort
the style the durability of the t-shirts
they make they fit perfectly they're not
scratchy they don't shrink they don't
fade they don't stretch out over time
like so many other t-shirts they're
really the most comfortable t-shirts
I've owned and they look great this
right here that I'm wearing on YouTube
is the split hem crew neck t-shirt very
soft fits me perfectly it's the ideal
length go take a look at what they offer
and once you have it you are really
going to see and feel the difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing you will see why and
you'll get 15% off when you do it by
going to david pakman.com slash cuts
that's david pakman.com slash c UTS